vous julien courbet je me suis fais
draguer effectivement par une star de la
télé une forêt dense et benoît du mag
energy on trouve que c'est un bon début
hélas dossier qui tombe sur julien
courbet abbas que s'arrête le prat dame
hérité dans un instant je vous le dire
maintenant
à arlon ce qui tourne sur vous dites
nous si c'est vrai il paraît que vous
êtes fait draguer par martine aubry quoi
suivante la vérité c'est pas vrai c'est
une bonne que je les envoyais et
messieurs producteurs qui me dit tu
étais déjà fait draguer par une somme
aux jouets en bois oui martine aubry
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
abraham et moi j'étais à 100 dès les 1er